like the song says we all want to change
the world and sometimes I get frustrated
in my attempts to do that but I just
finished reading a really amazing book
that gave me some insights into how it
might more well be possible Drex here
from drexfactor POI sharing with you the
love of poi spinning and flow Arts to
benefit your body and brain and today
I'm getting a little bit off of the
beaten path of flow Arts but still
talking about brainy stuff and namely
how we get people to change their minds
but before we dive in I just want to
give a quick shout out to the Friends of
the channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyro Terra light toys spin balls
and Ultra POI for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all of these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links that
I've got down in the description of this
video and special thanks to the
non-business friend of the channel Becca
beckonen thank you so much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission y'all it is cooking today in DC
we are up in the 90s with something like
57 humidity so um I'm not going to make
this as long as I normally would if for
no other reason that I'm going to be
sweating to the oldies here pretty soon
but I just finished reading this really
fantastic book called How Minds change
by a guy named David mccraney and I'm
still digesting in my head some of the
stuff that he dropped in this book not
the least of which because it challenges
a lot of my assumptions about how
exactly we engage in discussions about a
variety of issues and more importantly
how we actually affect real change now
this was probably one of the most
difficult books that I have read since
thinking fast and slow and a big part of
the reason was a lot of it challenged my
own thinking so the theory of change
that I've been operating from these past
few years has kind of revolved around
two specific pillars one of which is
rationality that is we put together a
well-reasoned argument based heavily on
the facts at and and that hopefully is
digestible enough that it can become a
meme in and of itself and is easily
passed from person to person the second
is that we make demonstrations of things
that is when there is an event that
happens or you know a a person place or
thing where the particular issues that
are involved in these individual kind of
arguments come up that we then go ahead
and make a lot of noise around them
and interestingly enough I after reading
this book I think maybe both of these
pillars are crumbling down in my head so
the book basically consists of the
author going around and interviewing
several people some of whom are
researchers in the field of cognitive
psychology and specifically work on the
question of how we get people to change
their minds others are people that have
changed their minds people that at one
point were members of the Westborough
Baptist church or were 9 11 conspiracy
theorists or what have you and
specifically asking them what the
process was by which they left those
belief systems and communities and came
to a new place of understanding kind of
fascinating I've got three major
takeaways from the book that really were
unexpected to me and I'd like to outline
to you what exactly the book says
actually is the method by which you can
get people to change their minds all
right so the first major takeaway for me
was that a lot of public debate
especially a lot of online debate is
extremely counterproductive it doesn't
really exist in a place where in people
are able to have a clash of ideas and
move the needle back and forth so much
as frequently it becomes more of a place
where people publicly identify an
opinion that becomes kind of an in-group
identifier that is somebody will say
something and somebody else will say I
agree with that and they recognize that
they are in community with each other
for that reason which is not to say that
debate cannot produce greater
understanding or move the needle back
and forth It's just that it tends to
happen in very specialized cases namely
cases wherein experts in a particular
field are debating back and forth the
information that they have at hand and
arguing over interpretations of it you
tend to have to have a prerequisite set
of specialized knowledge in order to
engage in these situations because you
have to come into it being willing to
say hey I have been I have been
presented with evidence that this
position is incorrect and thus I'm going
to move my position on it which many of
us don't they've done brain scans of
people being presented information that
runs contrary to their deeply held
beliefs and it actually shows up in
their brain almost literally as being
physically in pain this is just a human
thing we have a degree of resistance to
changing our ideas about things and as
it turns out there's a lot of reasons
why that's not such a bad thing for a
social primate to have going on in their
brains and that brings us to interesting
takeaway number two so here's the thing
most of the time when we ask people to
change their opinions on things most of
the time when we ask people to change
their ideas what we think we are doing
is ushering them into a new
understanding of the world and an
improved role for everybody and what we
fail to have understand in most of those
cases is that what we're actually asking
them to do is sign up to be treated as a
scapegoat by people that they have been
considering their friends family and
perhaps co-workers we are asking people
essentially to give up Social ties which
when we once again are social primates
that is asking a lot of people it very
literally is asking them to do one of
the most painful things that human
beings can receive like it's kind of
fascinating one of the stories that
shared in the book is about a young man
who was in the Westboro Baptist Church
and eventually left due to medical
reasons namely he had a very serious
medical problem that he was unable to
seek treatment for because seeking
treatment for it ran counter to the
church's beliefs so after he had been
excommunicated he finally reached a
point where he had no more community and
it was only then that he was receptive
to the fact that many of the teachings
of the Westboro Baptist Church are quite
hateful and he was able to change the
way that he looked at the world and many
of the specific tenets of that faith it
was only after he'd already lost that
community that he became capable of
opening his mind to those other
possibilities and the final takeaway and
one which became oddly timely as I was
reading this book is that more than
anything else people are incredibly
sensitive to being shamed that is those
moments when we think that we are
creating a moment of demonstration that
this is bad and people who do this are
bad very frequently has the opposite
effect to the one that we intended
namely people when they feel that amount
of Shame will then say that the people
making them feel that shame are the bad
ones this is painful I don't want to go
through this I will admit historically I
have been one of those people that says
well you know get over it deal with the
shame work through the shame
thing is though all of us are bad at
this every single one of us hate feeling
shame and it is very very difficult for
any one of us to work through
so in a lot of ways asking that somebody
just deal with that is kind of
unempathetic and don't get me wrong
there are many many many situations in
which a person has to just work through
the shame that they are experiencing as
a result of doing harm to another person
but when we kind of
ask people to do that without
understanding what it is that we're
really asking from them or even
recognizing the degree to which we avoid
doing that ourselves
well
it kind of creates a scenario where
people are going to be very very
heatedly arguing and not a lot is going
to come out of it now do bear in mind
that this is just my summary and it is
an imprecise one the book presents no
less than three specific approaches to
being able to change people's minds and
as it turns out each of them Works in
slightly different circumstances and for
slightly different purposes but overall
the six steps I'm about to outline are a
pretty good rough idea of what that
process looks like so Step One is if
you're going to engage in one of these
discussions you first have to open up a
rapport with the person and this is
really really important because you have
to establish some measure of trust to do
that
you need to make clear to them that you
have no intentions of shaming or
humiliating them and you actually have
to follow through on that promise that
is the only way that they're going to be
vulnerable enough to be able to open up
and share with you number two you ask
them to present a claim uh Perhaps it is
a position on a controversial issue
Perhaps it is a deeply held opinion or
belief after they present that claim
it's time to start examining it and how
do we do this well that brings us to
step three which is that we ask them to
give us a degree of certainty that they
have in this claim have them express it
as a percentage you want to ask them why
they assigned that specific percentage
to it
if they assigned a relatively low
percentage why the low percentage if
they assign the high percentage then
it's time time to move on to step four
so step four in this is to specifically
ask them what their reasons are for
having that level of confidence in the
claim what evidence do they have to back
that up what experiences do they have
that have contributed to that belief and
now with the claim delivered with their
level of confidence established and with
their reasons for that level of
confidence established
believe it or not the next step is
you try and repeat back to them what you
understand of their position and why
they have it in your own words and you
ask them if your restatement of that
opinion and the reasons for it are
accurate if they disagree that the way
you have characterized their position is
accurate ask them for clarification and
take in their feedback and keep on
working until
they are happy with you expressing their
opinion and the reasons for it in your
own language and now the final step
believe it or not it's that you wrap
things up you thank them for their time
and uh you send them off on their merry
way
why because quite frankly the purpose of
this isn't necessarily to bombard them
with a counter argument or rebut any of
their particular points but to kind of
ask them how they've arrived at where
they have and in a lot of cases in
trying to outline their position to
somebody else they're going to discover
that one or more reasons that they have
to hold the opinion that they do might
not be as solid as they originally
thoughts but and here's the real key
they have to get there by themselves you
cannot tell them they're wrong you
cannot tell them they have placed too
much confidence in a specific piece of
evidence they have to arrive there
themselves or it doesn't work and I know
this is deeply unsatisfying because it
flies in the face of so much of what we
want to believe about how progress is
made and how the human mind works of
course there are some variations in this
depending upon which specific technique
is being employed in some cases there
will be moments where the interviewer
asks a person can you remember a time in
your life before you came to this
position and what it was that
specifically got you there and or they
might present an experience from
somebody who is on the opposite side of
that particular position that is their
life has been impacted by it and why
um but yeah it doesn't really
necessarily involve directly arguing
with their conclusions or their reasons
for them so I will admit this is really
really tough for me but I will also say
the book makes a really compelling
argument and it sits on a really good
body of research
the problem is of course that this is a
technique that takes a very long time
usually multiple interventions with a
person and it takes an enormous amount
of attention and energy to make work
also it does need to be said that this
is an imprecise summary of the book
itself I don't have the author to talk
to to double check and see hey am I
presenting your conclusions correctly
here so if you take away nothing else
from this video read the book I'll leave
a link to it down in the description of
this video have you ever gotten somebody
to change their mind on something how
did you do it leave me a comment and let
me know did you get anything out of this
please leave a like comment share and
subscribe to help other people find it
this video would not be possible without
the kind support of all of these awesome
people right here these are my flow
patrons over on patreon they and the
people listed down in the description
help to make this video and all the
videos on this channel possible thank
you one and all for your very generous
supports and if any of you out there
watching right now are not currently as
supporters but you like to become
supporters you can do that by heading on
over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up
there you'll get access to a whole host
of awesome rewards but even better than
that you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring voice spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world and
occasionally sharing interesting things
I've learned as in this video so go
check that out please and thank you and
if you'd like to check out some other
videos I have amusing about topics like
this one I'll go ahead and include a
link to a playlist of said videos down
in the description as well as up on
screen if you are watching on YouTube
thanks so much for watching make sure to
go out and flow today and I'll see you
with a new video real soon
peace